you were interested in comedy at a very
early age right yeah it's a thing where
again this is this is just we were
talking about david letterman earlier
for me you were like letterman because i
didn't watch letterman so i just that
was comedy it was to me it was the
simpsons snl seinfeld and and and conan
was late night to me so this is a weird
thing for me well uh that's very cool of
you to say um and uh we're just gonna
put that on the loop
if you don't mind we're just gonna put
that over and over and over again truly
it's more of a function of my age it's
not like i like you better than letter
that's just exactly it's really just no
exactly
exactly you just weren't alive uh when
dave was hitting it out of the park
that's all i'll start first of all by
congratulating you on on the podcast uh
you're doing with with mr rob lowe and
it's called parks and recollection this
is a show that i'm very excited about
yes full disclosure it's part of our
team coco uh empire if you will
but you guys talking about that show
which i really admire which you uh wrote
on and so you have all this access to
how it was put together as does rob from
a different angle sounds like a very
cool project yeah and it has n you
producing has nothing to do with me
being here zero oh not at all
you know let me tell you something um
alan i'm at a point in my career
uh where i don't even know what i'm
involved in anymore so it's an empire
it's an empire it's a shondaland you you
know no it really is it really is i am
and so there are there are times where
people remind me hey conan you have a
big part of exxon mobil right like
you're a major stock holder uh and i'm
like oh i didn't know and that's when
you encourage them to just forget safety
precautions send the boats out there no
matter what the weather conditions are
just hey they're getting paid
the last time i checked they were
getting money and i say if there's a
rough seas
in the north atlantic get out there and
get the oil that's what i say to them
who cares where the icebergs are no but
the the podcast no the podcast has been
really fun we just started recording it
and uh god at first to be honest i was
like i don't know if i want to watch all
these episodes again it's a lot of times
let's let's bring people up to date you
yeah you worked for were you there the
entire time i was there for 125 episodes
as far as writers go
mike sure the co-creator and me i think
we're the only ones who were there the
whole time so right yeah so and so um
you were there at that show and i
remembered uh i'm obviously very good
friends with greg daniels who uh who was
responsible for bringing the office uh
to united states and then of course uh
you know had a hand in in getting parks
and rec going
and so uh
i
was very familiar with both shows and i
remember the office had kind of a slow
start
initially
and then took off parks and rec
it didn't happen right away for parks
and rec it's still taking off now it's
2021 i think you know it it was though
season one it was it was definitely
almost an identical trajectory to the
office and i think for similar reasons
because if you look at the office what
greg did with the office again a
brilliant show he's adapting it from a
british one and so the the first season
is a little bit closer to the british
one and then the second season kind of
sprouts its wings and and flies on its
own and becomes its own thing and parks
and rec started as was conceived at
first was maybe going to be an office
spin-off and then it wasn't and so that
first season i think mike and greg were
still trying to work out kinks and
trying to okay how different from the
office tonally etc right and then second
season it really starts taking off and
part of that was taking on amy poehler's
personality as well and and making use
of her so a really good tv show in my
opinion
is not a finite thing it's an organism
the shows i've always really loved if
you look at the simpsons for example you
can look at the first season
and dan castelnetta does not have
homer's voice yet yeah his way into
homer was he sort of thought of his
voice as being a walter matthau kind of
voice and you can listen to that first
year of the simpsons
and it's a lotta boy yeah it's a lot of
boys boy get here boy now you will send
me and then it it changes and then they
find it and i think shows like a lot of
things
and probably like a restaurant or
you know so many endeavors you need to
figure it out you need to you find it by
doing it and
i think people sometimes misunderstand
and think uh it's a widget it's
something that's manufactured and you're
cranking them out and you do 22 and then
the next 22 the only way you really know
what your show is is by doing it my late
night shows were constantly
changing and morphing and often
sometimes not by design it was just
sheer desperation
we don't have anything today i know
let's what if a bear masturbated uh and
then suddenly you're off on that and
you've hit what many call a renaissance
form of television
television in general just as far as
masturbation humor goes i think
quite fairly a renaissance but but yeah
it's it's it's fascinating to me that
these things and
evolve and uh it's it was not all
assigned on day one it's fascinating
it's exactly what you said which is and
you lived on the long end of this right
you're doing a daily show a show
you can really react to what the
audiences think you know how they're
reacting right what you're like as a
host what andy's doing whatever all of
that stuff you can react it's a read and
react type thing and so
with a show like parks they don't make
that shows that run that long anymore so
you know we went on to do master of none
it's been six years we've done 25
episodes of master you know it's like
it's crazy aziz aziz is now i i i tuned
in the other day he's 65 years old yeah
uh and he he's on his third hip yeah yes
that kind of television where you're
just cranking it out every day and going
through
uh massive arcs sort of creative arcs
over three month periods yeah
uh and and you know people saw it or
they didn't there was no checking it out
later on online now when you go back and
watch it
and for a lot of people for the first
time
they say wait a minute there's something
going on here and i think that's what's
happened with parks and rec is that it's
enjoyed
a renaissance i'm friends with nick
offerman and he said the same thing like
this is this is fascinating that people
are finding the show now
uh and we it's been what has it been 10
years since you guys made one yeah and
it's a fun as hell rewatch that's what
i'm realizing while re-watching it it
it's almost perfectly designed for right
now 2020 2021 the darkest time in a long
time where everyone's indoors you're
looking for something warm something
heartfelt something comforting it's a
great rewatch i'm i sound like an nbc
executive right now but but literally
like while watching it it's yeah i was
going into uh night terrors yeah yeah uh
just
something i i smell sulfur in the room